صور كهذه كانت كافيه لارسال رساله واضحه
فالنظام في ايران لن يوفر طريقه للبقاء
ولو بقمع المحتجين واعتقالهم ومحاكمتهم
وحتى الحكم على بعضهم بالاعدام
والاعطاء طابع قانونيين لعمليات القمع
يحاول النظام الحصول على اعترافات من
الموقوفين وطريقته واحده الضغط والتعذيب
بعدها تبث الاعترافات على وسائل الاعلام
الرسميه هذا ما جرى مع عشرات الموقوفين
ومن بينهم مغني الراب الايراني المعروف
باغانيه الداعمه للاحتجاجات العامه
والاضطرابات العماليه خلال السنوات
الاخيره
لم يكتفي بالاغاني التي نشرها وتفاعل معها
الشارع الايراني بل ابهرت مقاطع فيديو
خروجه لمشاركته في المظاهرات الشعبيه التي
عمت البلاد
بل وخرج ايضا في مقطع فيديو مصور يطالب
فيه المسؤولين الايرانيين بالهروب في
اشاره منه على توسع الاحتجاجات في ايران
اعتقلت السلطات الايرانيه توماج وبعدها
بايام بثت له فيديو يتراجع فيه عن ما قاله
في الفيديو الذي خاطب فيه المسؤولين
الايرانيين ويقول اخطات لم اكن اقصدكم
الفيديو الذي يثبت تعرضه ماجد صالح
للترهيب والتعذيب نشراته وكاله انباء
تسنيم وفارس بهدف ارسال رساله تهديد
وتخويف للمتظاهرين المستمرين في
احتجاجاتهم
الاعترافات القسريه من المعارضين
السياسيين والنشطاء المدنيين وتصويرها
وبثها على وسائل الاعلام الحكومي ليست
جديده
ولم تقتصر على الموقوفين الايرانيين بل
ايضا على موقف للجنسيات اجنبيه وهو ما دفع
عده دول من بينها المانيا لدعوه مواطنها
لمغادرته ايران سلطان العربيه